Machine learning is all about learning from examples.
So I'm going to teach you something right now from example,
something that you almost certainly don't already know.
That is whether a horse is acerous.
Do you know what acerous means?
>> What is acerous?
>> I'm not going to tell you.
>> [LAUGH] >> I'm going to give you a bunch of.
>> Then teach me. >> I'm going to give you a bunch of examples.
And then the question for you is whether you think a horse is acerous or not.
>> Okay.
So here's, here's some example animals.
>> It's made in China.
>> Has nothing to do with it being acerous.
These are some examples I'm going to tell you for
each one whether it's acerous or not.
An elephant is acerous.
A ram is not acerous.
Let's see a triceratops, the dinosaur, is non acerous.
Lemurs are acerous.
A dog is acerous.
A giraffe is non acerous.
A goat, also non acerous.
A cat is going to be acerous.
Parrot is acerous, and last a deer is non-acerous.
And so the question for
you is, which one of these groups would you put the, the horse in with?
>> It's hard.
I guess it looks a bit like a giraffe, maybe it's on that side.
Doesn't look like a parrot.
I put it here.
>> Okay, so you, this is the, this is the non-acerous group.
>> Yeah.
>> Now how confident are you at this?
>> I'm not at all.
>> Okay. >> If I give you 100,000 examples would you be more confident do you?
>> Yes. Please give me 100,000 examples.
>> These are all the toys I could find.
So before we go any further I'd like you to give me your answer of
what you think, what you think for the horse is.
Is it asorus or non-asorus.
Just based on the examples here